hey guys it's densify to thank you and
I'm David Griffin your resident comic
book in video game guru and this is our
review of agents of shield episode 21
the second-to-last episode this season
an ultimate episode SAT idle ragtag okay
so I I thought it was a good decent
episode I was kind of disappointed just
because i thought you know with this
whole back story with Geraden ward I
thought it would just go deeper and
maybe a little darker than what they
showed like the whole big like secret
was that he got pulled out of military
school or he had like done like oh is it
he was like a pyromaniac cuz he said you
did you know your brother or something
was in the house when he set the house
on fire or something like that something
like that I heard some day and he pulled
him out of juvie all right and then
let's move the woods for six months and
train him up so I thought it was gonna
be a little I don't know something a
little darker and it's something that
would have created more loyalty between
the two yeah I guess the thing is for me
I guess my expectations for the show
solo any any moments of levity I
appreciate so that I liked this episode
better than most and I have the past few
I think this cos Bill Paxton yeah he's
great he may eat elevates the show I
think he's he's a great I hope I mean we
know there's gonna be a big duel between
probably you know him and Coulson or him
and ward next week who knows looks like
but looks like i should say maybe we'll
go this later but word is bad and still
is bad i hope he remains that way the
one thing i did like it was all the
flashback stuff i did like how they tied
the whole dog into it you know he's like
you see him let the dog go hey like oh
he has a heart he's a good guy but then
when Fitz and you know Simmons are
telling him like don't do this don't do
us and they show the flashback again
then I could show him shooting the dog
but you see him lying up in his sniper
rifle after he's left the dog go she
like he's like no way you know that's
weakness and then he drops but like you
know they're not dead no no no there's
gonna be in underwater somebody come
rescue them i kinda [ __ ] would have
killed him that would have been
interesting but that's not gonna happen
okay i don't think the actors would like
that too much no another counter out of
a job right the v8 of a job that was the
best part because okay part of my
disappointment as well as that i didn't
feel like the
no was able to weave in the flashbacks
as well as they could uh except for that
part I think the part with the dog at
the end how he couldn't kill the dog at
point-blank range but from far away he
could do it right and weaving that in
with Fitz and Simmons and trying to kill
them I think that worked well yeah
however I thought the rest of the
episode would be more like that I mean a
show that I you know you haven't seen
all of it but I think you've price seen
enough of is lost they do a lot of
flashbacks awesome interracial and they
do a really good job what they do is
they somatically weave in a certain
character in his past or her past oh
yeah and like something that in their
life and they tied into the present day
and how that affects their
decision-making in their in their
thought process and so we saw a little
that with get away with wartime the
other time at the very end but I wish
there was more of that yeah I think that
those moments were the strongest of the
episode the garret Ward all the
flashbacks were great again everything
else like talking about the lady in the
flower dress talking about Skye and her
her religion her super DNA I don't ya
hey I don't care what sue me I don't
care what the parents were looking
forward to take her out of the village
like I don't I don't care about her
sounds like she's like I'm a sire
something like I just don't care about
who she is really she just still does
not interest me but all the wards stuff
I really appreciate and I loved having
bill paxton back oh yeah bill paxton is
what at least since he's been on this
show his right has brought his good this
show up it he's a good villain that's
why I don't want to see him die either
me at the end of this episode like when
they inject the synthesized serum of the
Aryan blood right in and there's a
moment you're like oh maybe he's gonna
die like I was like if he dies they're
gonna lose like a lot of the the best
parts of this show right yeah yeah I
mean there's and then I mean we saw may
but then it's like it's just that I
don't know just that whole group
together right now isn't it was I see
Mike a little bit you saw him last week
more so I'm a little bit this week you
know Peterson seen death lock and all
that stuff but I feel like shield never
sounds silly cuz it's a Marvel show they
never get into the geeky stuff enough
and i don't mean what i mean by that is
a they have their show they had their
setup they have their characters but
like they're in this like comic book
universe like they can do anything they
can bring any crazy character they want
to but the show again just keeps playing
it safe well I think I those is the
mutant they have to say loyal to the
Marvel Cinematic not only that I think
it's money I mean they're like you know
you have a really cool character can do
all these cool things yeah they do it's
come about but money I mean look at
Deathlok like a cheesy is costume yeah
right yeah and I mean we did learn that
Garrett was like the first patient zero
yeah the thing um but yeah I think it's
money they you know they if you get a
cool character villain or hero they just
can't budget-wise broke that in right
and everybody keeps saying I don't know
if this is joy don't think it's true
because it's never to do in there up
fronts right now they're announcing what
there's fall schedules are gonna be like
people keep saying like oh I heard the
show's already renewed I don't believe
that's been officially announced though
I don't know I almost feel like you got
it probably is maybe it was like
secretly like we were like it's renewed
but like no one's talking about it but
it may be III don't doubt I've a feeling
the product renew it even if it I think
the property is too big and even though
the ratings have gone down I mean this
was tied for the lowest ratings that
agents of shield so how are ya 5.37 so i
think but the name is big enough where
they'll give it one more Stephen season
just to give it a chance yeah i think so
i would i know they won't do this but i
would love to see a condensed season
maybe do like 13 episodes like this is
like Briggs last season of fringe 13
episode of something like I think this
season would have been better the first
season would remember if it had been
condensed and older small they would
have you know done a lot better starting
in January right yeah I didn't care for
the Trojan horse stuff that we've seen
them before take the little thing go to
a computer plug it in and then all
either all the secrets will get revealed
or all the secrets will get destroyed
blah blah blah we've seen that before
and so like when they talked about that
stuff and going to cybertek I was like I
did like the kind of a trip and how his
uh what is it his is it his grandma that
was like part of the howling command
oh yeah so he brought back yeah those
nice mom although hair dryer yes thought
that was funny I thought it was fun just
to be like when he takes out things like
one of those things that shocks you when
you shake hands like why would he have
that he's like yeah that's me I'm a
jokester yeah yeah that was fun as I can
EMP or something so I thought that was
kind of you know more on the fun side
for this show and in the way that Agent
Coulson was kind of like going geeky
over and him in and trip were having a
moment kind of reminded me of the you
know when he met captain america in the
avengers movie and he was like i got
your trading cards like they're in mint
condition like could you saw you know i
wanted to sign them or something like
that one of those kind of moments yeah
and then also at the very end we see the
the quinn guy who's now working for
Garrett mmm trying to sell these you
know basically the deathlok program to
the US government right yeah you're not
knowing that he's actually representing
Hydra yeah yeah so we'll see where that
goes I mean next week's the finale so
yeah yeah well so this makes you see
what they leave it hopefully they've
saved the most of the budget and and
most of the good story moments for this
episode because they really want people
to come back and see next to you do if
it does come back duska back alright
guys so that's what you thought of the
episode you can post your comments below
on the website think hero.com or on our
youtube channel think here I'll pro make
sure to subscribe to that you also find
us on Twitter Dennis myself from Michael
role at at think hero i'm at griffin de
and we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you like that page and share our
videos and on Twitter and Facebook and
anything else
you